so today we're going to do something we
haven't done in a while and that's a rap
review uh to be honest i just i i
haven't been inspired by any new jams in
quite a while i haven't had a moment
where
i hear something and i think well geez
that shows fire
that is until i came across this song
it's listed on youtube as ybn
nemir apostopa feat 21 savage
now as far as i can tell there are two
people and a song title
here but only one actual word so i'm not
sure what what's happening exactly i'm a
little bit confused but this is a
popular song i know that um the kids
love it my four-year-old was was bumping
to it
earlier this morning so it's a really
popular song we'll give it a shot here's
apostopa with the song
why be in the mirror either that or it's
ybn to mirror with the song apostol
in any case uh let's let's check it out
here we go
he called them if i heard correctly he
called them
pancake ass n-words you know i'm not
sure what that means
i assume it isn't good if somebody
accuses you of being a pancake ass
it's probably safe to assume they're not
trying to compliment you i would think
i'm not sure though you know i don't
know what the exact nature of the insult
is
and even though i don't know what the
insult means i it kind of makes sense in
a way and i've noticed that rappers are
very good at doing this
where they say something that on one
level you think wait a second that's
completely incoherent
but on another level you think yeah but
i sort of understand what you mean
so i i can kind of see why i might go up
to a guy and say
say like you pancake ass fool
look at pancake over here with this
pancake ass
i mean i don't think i would ever say
that to anybody but uh at least
at least ybn amir ken
[Music]
i keep a rocket in my pockets i get
caught a pocket rocket if it's war
we ain't playing games baby getting
started
[Music]
when it's beef we ain't playing yo mama
know that chopper that's that i
stopped
there are so many elements of this scene
that we have to sort through
like there's a guy on a cell phone that
was made in 1998
they've also got brand new iphones and a
tv
that somebody watched the moon landing
on in 1969
they got all this cash on the table and
ybn says that he fell in love with the
money
it's a very financially confused scene
is what i'm saying you need to diversify
your bonds
plus they've got a window ac unit in the
house
with all that money you could you got
you got hundreds of just thousands of
dollars sitting on the table take some
of that
you could easily pay for central ac take
a few wads of that cash
head down to home depot talk to somebody
about getting you an hvac unit for the
house now in this case that's a house
with with
it's it's not a lot of square footage
there so um
hvac system is going to pay for itself
in energy savings over the years
and these are all things that i could
explain if ybn
and 21 savage were to invite me to their
barbecue and i frankly think that most
rapper crews
need a white dad and a flannel at the
barbecue
just dropping a little bit of dad
knowledge that that's that's my theory
anyway
[Music]
why your girlfriend always wanna touch
[Music]
baby
when i listen to these lyrics and i try
to process the message
i can't help but pick up on very heavy
dr seuss influences in the rhyme scheme
and who's canceled now by the way for
being racist
but he's he i think he should get credit
for it for influencing much of modern
rap
like he says in the first verse i keep a
rocket in my pocket socket called a
pocket rocket
which is very similar to soos when he
wrote about the wokkit in the pocket
one of my favorite dr seuss books
growing up um and really in both cases
you
you become a little uncomfortable
because it sounds vaguely sexual
and then ybn says on the hook he says uh
here's what he says
know that choppa that's the apostopa hit
you and your partners
i fell in love with all this money you
in love with drama
say say baby i'm not sosa baby but i
keep a llama
gonna pull up in a new i8 you riding in
a honda
and i love that because of the way that
he advocates for
responsible farming practices and he
says he has a llama i'm a little worried
about there isn't enough room
to house a llama on that uh postage
stamp yard there but uh
i'll assume he's rented out a barn or
something like that some farmland
somewhere
but basically he has gotten into animal
husbandry
and he he's advocating for it in this
song that's what i'm picking up on
i could imagine him maybe going and
performing this song
uh about raising llamas maybe to a 4-h
club for kids
or something like that so i now i'm
getting into the song i'm saving 21.
touch your baby
mama in the air like she a salad ratchet
stop me while i'm driving she from daddy
but mama got some buns on her i call her
paddy twenty my mother
be smoking all the wood she from
california in my testosterone my pistol
out the host
i'm double cupping syrup i don't need no
coastal facts i
smell my fragrance you can't tell me i
ain't rich it full air ain't shaking no
hand with no snitch
there's a few things that i appreciate
here as we hear 21 savage come and
deliver his verse spit his bars
first i love that 21 savage really gives
the impression of somebody who doesn't
want to be in the music video at all
i'm not even supposed to be here today
he seems very put out
like he doesn't want to be at the party
everybody else is throwing cash around
you know really
really doing doing the apostopa 21
savage is off in the corner
and when it's his turn to rap he's kind
of like rolling his eyes and saying fine
okay i'll spit some bars if you want me
to
and he comes with let's be honest some
pretty lazy material
you could tell that he wasn't ready for
this like he showed up to the house
and they're getting ready for the music
video and he said oh is that today
grabbed a napkin ran to the kitchen
wrote his verse in about four minutes
and that's how we get lines like this he
says lil mama got some buns on her i
call her patty
do you really though do you really call
her patty because of her buns
i i don't think you do maybe 21 savage
can get away with a line like that i
don't think i could
if i was single no way i could walk up
to a woman and say hey uh
couldn't help but notice your buns say
do you mind if i call you patty
no that wouldn't work for me i would get
quote mode on that sexual harassment
claims
everything but i'm not 21 savage so he
can do that speaking of which i also
liked how 21 savage said his name
21 after every line
so it goes he says little mama got some
buns on her i call her patty
21 my motto be smoking all the woods
she from cali 21. rolling loud miami i
pull up with 10 sticks
21. smell my fragrance you can tell me i
ain't rich
21. big 4l i ain't shaking no hand with
no snitch
21. so it's almost like it's like
memento
or something where he has no short-term
memory and so he has to remind himself
who he is every two seconds
and that's smart because you don't want
to have an existential crisis in the
middle of the rap
where you forget who you are where you
are
why you are the only thing i'll say is
that and i and look i don't mean to
harsh anyone's
anyone's a vibe okay i don't mean to
harsh any buzzes here but
again as the white dad in in the flannel
at the barbecue marijuana
does affect short-term memory so if
you're having trouble remembering things
from one moment to a next
you have to remind yourself who you are
in the middle of the song
then maybe i would think about not
smoking
that good quite so often that's that
happens
baby i'm not salsa baby
well look at least they at least they
blur out the middle fingers in the end
that literally a whole song about drugs
guns
hoes but the middle finger at the end is
a bridge too far
and i appreciate that i mean in the last
verse the guy
was talking about drinking and driving
while holding a loaded pistol in his
hand
on his way to murder someone while
wearing a watch that he bought with drug
money
but you wouldn't want something really
inappropriate like a crass hand gesture
in your music video
we all have standards even ybn and 21
savage do
and that i think is the silver lining